Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Lors d’un entretien d’embauche
au musée des Beaux-Arts
d’une petite ville suisse perchée
à 1000 mètres d’altitude,
on m’a demandé
ce que je ferais pour m’intégrer.
Du tac au tac et sans trop réfléchir,
j’ai répondu :
« Je me mettrai au ski de fond
et je lirai les œuvres complètes
de Monique Saint-Hélier. »
Monique Saint-Hélier est une auteure
à la prose rêche et vaste
comme les paysages qui l’ont vu grandir.
Une auteure à la prose ardue
mais magistrale.
Bien sûr, à l’époque,
je n’en avais pas lu une seule ligne.
J’ai accepté le job et me suis installée
à La Chaux-de-Fonds.
Je me suis efforcée
de me mettre au skating.
C'est difficile.
J’ai chuté, chuté encore,
rechuté, j’ai échoué.
Mais par contre, j’ai lu Monique
Saint-Hélier et pas seulement.
J’ai arpenté les rues de ma nouvelle ville
telle une excursionniste professionnelle.
J’ai dévoré des livres sur son histoire,
consommé sa littérature,
découvert son architecture
et surtout, j’ai étudié sa peinture.
Anecdote mise à part,
cette réponse lancée de manière spontanée,
dit ce qui fait que l’on s’ancre,
que l’on s’attache,
que l’on crée un sentiment
d’appartenance à un lieu.
Pour moi, c’est évident,
c’est d’une part la nature
et d’autre part la culture.
Ce qui fait le cœur de cette ville,
la Chaux-de-Fonds,
ce qui compte vraiment,
outre l’horlogerie,
c’est ce que la culture y a produit.
Et ce qu’elle y a produit,
ce sont de grands artistes.
Ce sur quoi la ville s’est construite,
ce sont ses mythologies artistiques.
Mais avez-vous déjà remarqué
que tous les grands artistes nés ici
ont dû partir pour mieux briller ?
Un certain Charles-Édouard Jeanneret
est parti fâché de la Chaux-de-Fonds,
il est allé à Paris
et il est devenu Le Corbusier.
Blaise Cendrars est allé bourlinguer
en Russie et ailleurs dès ses 17 ans.
Même Monique Saint-Hélier a dû
s’exporter pour mieux écrire son pays.
Léopold Robert est parti
à 16 ans pour Paris,
où il s’est formé à la gravure
puis à la peinture
dans l’atelier du maître incontesté
du néoclassicisme,
Jacques-Louis David.
Comment se fait-il que ces artistes
qui sont tous partis
ont construit l’identité d’une ville
qui ne les a jamais vu revenir ?
En arrivant sur mon nouveau territoire,
je pensais connaître
un peu la peinture de la région.
Et pour moi la peinture de la région,
c’était ça :
les doux et rassurants paysages du Jura,
les vertes et tendres prairies dans
lesquelles l’envie nous vient de rouler,
les sombres et denses forêts
de Charles L’Éplattenier.
Dans le musée dans lequel
je commençais à travailler,
je me familiarisais petit à petit
avec les collections.
Alors que j’errais dans les dépôts
sans autre but que
de m’imprégner du génie du lieu,
je tombais à chaque fois sur ce tableau.
Et je me disais :
« Vraiment, mais pourquoi ? »
Je ne comprenais pas.
Il s’agit d’un tableau de Léopold Robert,
celui qui justement a quitté
sa ville natale pour Paris
et qui a fait presque
toute sa carrière en Italie.
Léopold Robert était l’une des stars -
ou plutôt la grande star -
de la peinture européenne
du premier tiers du XIXᵉ siècle.
Mais comment se fait-il
qu’il ait connu un tel succès ?
Comment se fait-il qu’il ait été
si connu à son époque ?
J’ai pour habitude de toujours laisser
une seconde chance aux artistes
et sur les grilles du dépôt de musée,
je trouvais également ceci.
Ici, c’est un ermite mort
retrouvé par un berger.
Ou encore cela.
Là, c’est une religieuse sur le point
de rendre son dernier souffle.
Je restais dans l’incompréhension
et je balançais
entre répulsion et fascination.
En un sens, une émotion vive
suscitée par une œuvre d’art,
c’est toujours quelque chose.
En tout cas, c’est mieux que rien.
Même si elle est négative.
Mais moi, je restais hantée
par l’image de cette femme pleurant
sur le corps sans vie de son enfant.
Pourquoi ?
D’une part, le pathos qui
s’en dégage résonnait en moi,
comme en toute personne,
j’imagine, dotée d’un cœur.
Ce tableau représente pour toutes et tous,
et a fortiori pour tout parent,
le pire des scénarios qui puisse arriver.
D’autre part, ce tableau,
même s’il est très sombre et funeste,
chaque détail a attiré mon œil
et m’encourageait à l’observer davantage.
Je regardais le visage blême
de la petite fille morte.
Le fil rouge noué à son orteil.
Le soin porté à l’exécution des vêtements,
au rugueux de la jupe de drap brun,
au soyeux des rubans
attachés à la ceinture,
à la finesse de la broderie
du lit de mort.
Je regardais le crucifix
abandonné par terre
qui signifie que cette douleur-là
est encore bien plus grande.
Je regardais l’instrument de musique,
inerte, attaché au mur,
qui nous rappelle
qu’après la vie continuera.
Je commençais alors à comprendre.
Après des siècles
de grande peinture d’histoire,
Léopold Robert, notre sauveur,
a enfin montré une vérité, une réalité,
que les gens de son temps
étaient enfin prêts à voir.
Un réalisme sans misérabilisme,
un regard presque ethnographique
sur les mœurs des populations
des campagnes italiennes.
Le grand critique Étienne-Jean Delécluze
disait à son propos en 1828 :
« L’artiste ne craint pas de peindre
la nature sur le fait,
et cependant,
par la grâce de son goût naturel
et par l’éclat de son style brillant
sans être recherché,
il donne du lustre
aux choses les plus communes
et joint parfois la grandeur
à la naïveté. »
Et c’est sans doute
cette exquise simplicité,
cette grâce sans mièvrerie,
ce naturel sans trivialité
qui ont fait son succès.
Si Léopold Robert est assurément
aujourd’hui bien connu des spécialistes,
en dehors de sa ville natale
dont l’artère principale porte le nom,
il est malheureusement un peu oublié.
Et encore, si demain matin je me rendais
sur l’avenue Léopold Robert
et que je demandais
aux passantes et aux passants :
« Qui est ce grand personnage ? »,
on me répondrait peut-être
qu’il était politicien.
D’aucuns me diraient peut-être
qu’il était peintre.
Mais qui vraiment connaît aujourd’hui
la vie et l’œuvre de cet artiste ?
Pourtant en son temps -
certes, c’était il y a 200 ans -
il connut la gloire.
Les collectionneurs
s’arrachaient ses tableaux.
Il était présent
dans les collections royales,
les collections d’État,
les collections privées
les plus somptueuses.
Il dut même appeler
son frère Aurèle à la rescousse
pour l’aider à produire
des œuvres en série,
tant les commandes étaient importantes.
Il a reçu des prix
dans les salons de Paris.
Il a été décoré de la Croix
de la Légion d'honneur.
Il était tellement connu
qu’il a même inspiré Balzac et Stendhal.
Mais comment se fait-il
qu’il ait été à ce point oublié ?
Et que faire pour y remédier ?
Ce ne sont plus des tableaux que
l’on aimerait avoir chez soi aujourd’hui.
Heureusement, il en a réalisé d'autres
dans un genre qu'il disait plus plaisant.
Il convient toutefois ici
de modérer mon propos.
Je parlais tout à l’heure
de vérité et de réalité.
Mais au fond,
tous les personnages de ses tableaux,
aussi pittoresques soient-ils,
sont une construction de leur auteur.
Léopold Robert faisait poser des paysannes
et des pêcheurs dans son atelier,
en les parents de costumes de fête
et de bijoux magnifiques.
Il dépeignait ces personnages
des classes populaires avec une dignité,
avec une noblesse,
et en donnant une dimension
parfois épique à ces scènes.
Les visages ont une noblesse
et une beauté idéalisée,
inspirées de l’Antiquité.
Même les brigands,
qu’il a souvent mis à l’honneur,
séduisent par leur aspect
proprement romantique.
Ces figures à la fois
terrifiantes et très populaires
symbolisaient courage et liberté.
Ainsi, l’artiste tentait d’élever
la peinture de genre
à la hauteur de la peinture d’histoire.
Il y a quelques années,
Léopold Robert a débarqué dans ma vie.
Avec mes collègues, nous avons
organisé une grande exposition.
Nous avons publié un livre,
nous avons organisé un colloque
et des visites guidées.
Nous avons restauré ses tableaux.
Tous ensemble, nous avons travaillé
à rendre son œuvre plus accessible
aux jeunes comme aux moins jeunes.
Mais qu’est-ce que ces tableaux
ont à faire dans la vie des gens ?
Et qu’est-ce que ces tableaux
ont à faire dans vos vies ?
Alors que les artistes
et leurs productions
ont souvent été relégués
aux marges de la société,
ils en constituent en fait les vestiges.
J’entends vestiges comme
une trace laissée, un souvenir.
Ce qui reste d’une chose qui est disparue.
Ces œuvres sont les vestiges
sur lesquels nous construisons des mythes
et c’est ce à quoi
nous travaillons aujourd’hui.
C’est aller élever cet artiste,
Léopold Robert, au rang de mythe.
Il avait déjà lui-même cette ambition
lorsqu’il écrivait à son frère en 1820 :
« Il faut que nous fassions
universellement parler des Robert. »
Et puis, il a terminé d’écrire son propre
mythe en se donnant la mort en 1835.
Le Corbusier, Blaise Cendrars,
Monique Saint-Hélier et Léopold Robert
font toutes et tous partie de
la construction mythique de notre ville.
Mais pourquoi est-ce important ?
C’est important parce
que la population s’identifie
aux récits de ces grands personnages.
C’est important car l’art suscite
des liens affectifs profonds,
des liens qui nous unissent.
C’est important car l’art
est un instrument privilégié
pour favoriser l'appartenance.
Enfin, l’art joue aussi
un rôle de catalyseur
et permet de dynamiser nos villes.
C’est la raison pour laquelle il me paraît
aujourd’hui toujours plus important
que la programmation artistique
de nos musées sensibilise le public
à son histoire culturelle,
que nos musées permettent
au public de se l’approprier,
que nos musées offrent également
des possibilités de contribuer
à la vie de la collectivité.
Depuis quelques années,
mes chaussures, mes bâtons
et mes skis de fond prennent
la poussière dans ma cave
et même s’ils reviennent comme par magie
au début de chaque saison devant ma porte,
je dois bien avouer que ce n’est pas
par mes talents sportifs
que j’ai pu m’intégrer.
En revanche, il y a quelques années,
j’ai laissé Léopold Robert
débarquer dans ma vie.
Et c’est sans doute en étudiant son œuvre
que je suis devenue chaudefonnière.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)